no gray hair here just a big bushy beard
from Matthew McConaughey in his new
civil war movie and by the way he became
the coolest dead ever when he brought
his oldest son Levi to the set he was
there live he also got to press the
buttons to explode a lot of it thank you
or at least he thought it was him doing
it all right it allows a lot of them
orders but it was the battles aftermath
in the civil war drama free state of
jobs that most affected seven-year-old
Levi and the Confederacy fighting in the
open sequence solving down man go Daniel
gets shot and all of a sudden I'm
looking for my son of fun
he's over there staring at this pile of
these dummies that look very real and I
walked over and just hid beside him for
better a minute he stared and he noticed
I was there and all of a sudden you go
by yes I don't want to go to war I was
like hey yeah I hear you by the way
Popeye is Papa in Portuguese which is as
brazilian-born wife Camilla's native
tongue so Matt do you have plans for
this Sunday's Diego spice I don't know
about him I had to be reminded follow
these days coming up but you damn right
I knew when Mother's Day was and we just
had to ask about this amazing viral
photo of a 19th century doctor which
some say proves Matthews a time traveler
I have seen its they doesn't go out like
me definitely a fake mustache I wouldn't
even wear that mustache
they desert go I like me